well now it's time we take a look at
what pizza art is like when it gets
boiled in an oven yeah but it wasn't
really I wouldn't say boiled but they
took I think very accurate portraits of
us depicted in pizza and then shoved
them into a would you say 750 degree
oven to 900 to 900 degree and now we get
to see what happened which one should we
start on okay we know where we should
start let's start on mine okay and this
is a wonderful depiction of me in about
six years
I don't even see that is me six years
from now oh I see it
this is every Uncle I ever knew
what happens to an O'Brien uh if we
don't put on sunblock and um
A's falling apart well and also the
pizza's not doing too well
yeah surprise
and your earring has moved up your head
yeah yeah so the heat I guess distorted
your ear you still have that wonderful
hair made of pepperoni which is not
unlike your own hair very high in sodium
and um very greasy yeah so you and I
look terribly distorted you know who
actually doesn't look bad Matt gorley
well that just means I'm pure of heart
and innocent of Soul no it just means
that you were meant to be a pizza
Sona and I were meant to be humans that
live on earth uh wait a minute I see
your glasses still yeah yeah you do look
like Rivers Cuomo after a terrible house
fire
um but that's a compliment yeah that's
an improvement yeah no no you look you
look fine I think we can all agree that
Matt your pizza depiction held up the
best under intense uh temperatures I win
this challenge you do Sona how do you
feel about the way you look you know
what I'm a little
um I'm I'm I don't I can see my eyes and
uh I don't think I'm I want to be a
pizza can I say something Sono yeah I
recognize this version of you it was
after we did a week of shows at
Comic-Con and you would hit the bars
every night yeah about four or five six
years ago that was what I would see in
the morning going
bum that was why I depicted yeah that's
what I saw that doesn't make any sense
and I um I just look like Irish people
do after a certain age there's nothing
we can do about it I want to eat myself
well I'm gonna move on okay it got
really quiet after I said that I'm a
Pizza it's not like I actually
want to eat myself can I quote you on
that I'm a piece I am I'm just
saying I want to eat my pizza okay all
right yeah why are you it's fine I don't
want any trouble from her Matt would you
distract this insane ball so I'm not
gored Governor Brian needs a friend is
brought to you by T-Mobile from
listening to your favorite podcast while
driving cross country to listening at
home T-Mobile helps you stay connected I
wonder what people's favorite podcast is
oh I've got some ideas actually it's one
idea yeah you'll figure it out T-Mobile
is America's largest and fastest 5G
Network you can have seamless video
calling oh that's good streaming your
favorite podcast I'm not gonna say which
one it is yeah downloading apps games
boy you know what a gamer I am you're
such a gamer play starbursters yeah or
realm of zados
you can watch favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at t-mobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA the speed test
intelligence data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access details at
t-mobile.com
hey I have an idea brought to me by
other people
let's eat our own faces I literally
to be fair okay you know what I don't
care anymore can we get our other faces
in here
yeah we're also gonna need we need to
cut our faces oh we do need
face cutters
you don't want to just peel it off
just grab a chunk do I want to eat my
chin my eye my forehead thank you this
looks amazing thank you so much how hot
is this or is it still it's cooled off a
bit it's cooled off okay I'm gonna take
some here's what I have to do first I
have to remove this offending oh look at
that a solo show a solo stove very
nicely incinerates the uh mushroom I do
not want to eat that's good cheek
um I'm going right for my jawline what
an iconic jawline oh my God oh my God
tastes good yeah
I look horrifying
but I taste good yeah there's been
loaded with cheese a lot of cheese
happening on Conan's okay I'm tasting
some amphetamines what's happening
incredible mine Taste of charm and
mm-hmm
and and why
how's your son again I understood
pepperoni mine's really good your kids
eat pizza your little twins yeah they
like pizza they don't eat it that much
but they like it what's their favorite
food yeah what's their favorite food
lamb chops and corn come on I'm not even
kidding my favorite food is lamb chops I
my favorite food is lamb chops you need
to leave what's your favorite food great
cereal what
waiting up for reals what is it my
favorite food bean and cheese burrito
that's lame
can I speak to you under the chair
please
I'm gonna call a new career low for me
I have talked to the greatest people in
the world and then with you two idiots
eating our own faces made of pizza
and you're having the dumbest argument
I've ever heard
and I just saw
that my career was over can I get a
napkin or am I in some kind of medieval
time
this is delicious this is really good
mine tastes fantastic mine's good too
but I'm really full and I'm I'm done
yeah oh thank you honey you know I'm
sitting under these stuff mom are there
any stars no no it's nice to be out here
yeah I'm enjoying myself I like being in
the night air yeah me too
um I'm enjoying the fraternity the
company and also the sorority thank you
it's nice this is nice this is really
nice I like summer s'mores I wish to do
it um in the winter we should have
winter s'mores and Autumn s'mores Autumn
s'more spring if we do spring
Sports I'm out
well I'll talk to the advertising
department and see if they can monetize
it we don't need an Advertiser we can
just do it because we're friends yeah oh
no I would never do this
I'm here because there's a commercial
tie-in
and the second there's not I'm out of
here you just said you like the company
yeah yeah I like the company and then
there's an asterisk at the end if it's
endorsed by a product I believe in like
solo stuff okay fantastic oh God my
pizza once the rest of the who wants the
rest of her she's got a lot of spunk
yeah take good care of him would your
are you trying to take my pizza
away from me
Jason schleming's been with me almost 30
years did you try and take a pizza away
from an Irish a giant Irish guy trying
to eat it I did I apologize did you
immediately realize the mistake I walked
away immediately yes it was like a great
white shark was chewing on a dead seal
and you were trying to take it away yes
mistake hey big guy could I try a piece
of your face get the out of me I
give give me a piece of your face or I
will quit do you need a thing no I need
a piece of face do you need you need a
thing turn off some face for uh what why
do I hold glasses over there call me old
glasses I don't know your name I don't
have a name